.
>> FIRST, THE GAME.
A HARD-FOUGHT BATTLE BACK AND
FORTH.
NO SURPRISE.
ULTIMATELY, YOU FALL SHORT.
WHAT DID IT COME DOWN TO?
>> WELL, I LO-- LOVE, REALLY, ME
SOME BIG BUCKETS AND OBVIOUSLY,
WE'D LIKE TO HIT OUR FREE
THROWS.
AND -- YOU KNOW, THE -- YOU
KNOW, MARK NOT BEING ABLE, YOU
KNOW, HE WAS NEVER IN -- IN THE
GAME AND OUR GUYS FOUGHT.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE REALLY GOOD.
THEY'RE REALLY GOOD.
THEY'RE EXPERIENCED AND THEY HIT
US WITH THAT ONSLAUGHT OF THREES
AND IT LOOKED LIKE, YOU KNOW, WE
WERE GOING TO GET BLOWN OUT OF
THE DOME AND THEN OUR GUYS CAME
BACK AND WE GOT THAT ONE-POINT
LEAD AND WE FOULED ON A -- AND
WE DID FOUL, YOU KNOW, BUT YOU
GOT TO PLAY DEFENSE AND MAKE
THEM SHOOT THE BALL.
AND THEN YOU GOT TO -- YOU GOT
TO PUT SOME FREE THROWS IN AND
PUT SOME GAME PRESSURE ON THEM,
BUT CONGRATULATIONS TO THEM, YOU
KNOW, THEY -- THEY'VE HAD --
THEY PLAYED AN OUTSTANDING GAME.
I THOUGHT BOTH TEAMS PLAYED
THEIR HEARTS OUT AND IT'S AN
EMOTIONAL WIN AND IT'S AN
EMOTIONAL LOSS.
AND THAT'S THE WAY A GAME LIKE
THIS SHOULD BE.
>> COACH, AS YOU WALKED OFF THE
COURT FOR THE FINAL TIME, CAN
YOU DESCRIBE THE EMOTIONS THAT
YOU WERE FEELING?
>> JUST FOR MYPLAYERS, YOU
KNOW?
I'LL DEAL WITH ME LATER.
I -- FOR ME, MY ENTIRE TIME
COACHING, I ALWAYS WANTED AT THE
END OF THE YEAR, WHATEVER THE
LAST GAME IS, WHERE YOU'RE
EITHER CRYING FOR JOY OR CRYING
FOR SORROW.
AND IF YOU ARE, THAT MEANS
YOU'VE PUT EVERYTHING INTO IT.
AND I HAVE A BUNCH OF KIDS WHO
ARE CRYING AND I'M PROUD OF
M
THEM.
THEY'VE BEEN A JOY TO COACH.
AND THEY'VE PLAYED WINNING
BASKETBALL.
AND THEY DID TONIGHT, TOO, BUT
SO DID THE OTHER TEAM.
>> THAT'S THE FINAL TEAM THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO COACH.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHAT WAS THE FINAL MESSAGE TO
THEM IN THERE?
>> NO, JUST HOW PROUD.
WE LOVE THEM.
AND THE BROTHERHOOD THAT THEY'VE
DEVELOPED, I MEAN, THEY'RE
DOUBLE CHAMPIONS, REGULAR
SEASON, WESTERN REGIONAL CHAMPS,
32 WINS, ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
AND THIS, MY FINAL YEAR WITH
THIS TEAM -- THEY'VE BEEN
MAGNIFICENT.
I'M -- I'M SO PROUD OF THEM.
AND I LOVE THEM.
AND SO, IT'S -- RIGHT NOW, IT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE CARE
OF THEM AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE OKAY.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE REALLY DOWN,
YOU KNOW?
AND ESPECIALLY YOUNGER PLAYERS,
YOU KNOW, THEY'LL LOOK AT A FREE
THROW AND SAY, I LOST THE GAME.
AND THAT'S THE OTHER THING, WE
TRY TO -- LOOK, ONE PLAY DOES
NOT WIN OR LOSE THE GAME.
DON'T BEAT YOURSELF UP.
YOU KNOW, WE -- WE HAD OUR
OPPORTUNITIES, THEY MADE ONE
MORE OPPORTUNITY THAN US AND --
BUT DON'T BEAT YOURSELF UP.
BECAUSE WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
WITHOUT THEM.
YOU KNOW?
THEY'VE ALL DONE THINGS TO GET
US THIS FAR, BUT I LOVE THE FACT
THAT THEY FEEL THAT BAD.
AND WE JUST HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM.
>> I KNOW I'M SPEAKING FOR ALL
OF COLLEGE BASKETBALL, BUT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU'VE
DONE.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
YEAH, IT'S -- OBVIOUSLY I'LL
DEAL WITH ALL OF THAT LATER, BUT
IT -- THIS TEAM'S BEEN A JOY FOR
ME TO COACH.
AND ESPECIALLY THEM TURNING IT
AROUND IN MARCH AND TO PUT US IN
A POSITION WHERE, YOU KNOW, WE
HAD A CHANCE TO PLAY ON MONDAY.
AND THAT'S THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS
TO PLAY ON MONDAY AND HAVE A
CHANCE TO WI